der berufssoldat weiterkam schilder den
polenfeldzug aus der perspektive des
einfachen front kämpfers er erlebt den
krieg in vorderster linie in seiner
ganzen brutalität
von anfang an wird der deutsche überfall
auf polen von einem besonderen phänomen
begleitet die angst der deutschen
soldaten vor zivilen heckenschützen
so berichtet auch walter k in seinem
tagebuch von einem guerillakrieg in dem
die wehrmacht geraten sei und er
schreibt von dem rigorosen vorgehen
seiner einheit abfackeln
[Musik]
alle dörfer werden von uns in brand
gesteckt nicht ein haus bleibt verschont
zahlreiche tagebücher und feldpostbriefe
berichten ähnliches kilometerweit
erstrecken sich die gehöfte alle stehen
in flammen
auch die begründungen gleichen sich es
sei die antwort auf den heimtückischen
widerstand von hecken baum oder dach
schützen von freischärlern oder
zivilisten und die erwartung auf
wehrmacht seite war dass die polnische
bevölkerung sich massiv die
zivilbevölkerung sich massiv am kampf
gegen die wehrmacht beteiligen würde
davon ging man als gegeben aus und
entsprechend formulierte man warnungen
an die truppe in denen wortwörtlich
stand die islamische bevölkerung ist
hinterhältig
da kann man niemandem trauen da sind
auch viele juden es werden mit
sicherheit brunnen vergiftet werden und
die zivilbevölkerung wird bei der
kleinsten gelegenheit der wehrmacht
bewaffnete den rücken fallen und so ist
es auch nicht verwunderlich dass die
wehrmachtsoldaten in allen gebieten die
sie erobern
rücksichtslos gegen die polnische
zivilbevölkerung vorgehen die sie
pauschal als partisanen verdächtigen
es ist die jagd auf ein phantom es
wurden keine partisanen einheiten
gebildet
es gab keine pläne größere sabotage
einheiten im rücken der deutschen armee
einzusetzen
in der polnischen kriegs doktrin war
auch kein rede davon die
zivilbevölkerung in den einzelnen orten
in die kämpfe mit einzubeziehen
[Musik]
waldacker schildert in seinen
aufzeichnungen wie seine einheit seit
tagen in schwere kämpfe verwickelt ist
und sich überall von freischärlern
bedroht sieht die ganze nacht wurden wir
beschossen
aber sie haben uns nicht geschnappt
jetzt setzt endlich eine große
säuberungsaktion in den ortschaften heil
überall werden polnische zivilisten und
soldaten herausgezogen
am leben blieb niemand alle hunde
erschossen
tatsächlich hat walter k in seinem
tagebuch festgehalten dass dass man
äußerst brutal gegen die bevölkerung in
gut wie nie vor regen und dass man sogar
die tiere und die hunde erschossen hätte
und interessanterweise findet sich genau
dieses detail auch in den
augenzeugenberichten die nach dem krieg
von menschen aufgezeichnet wurden die
eben diesen einmarsch der deutschen post
wie nie erlebt haben so berichtet eine
polnische augenzeugen jahre nach dem
krieg die deutschen fahren und laufen
bataillons weise richtung warschau im
dorf liegen viele tote pferde für und
gänse herum
die häuser sind verbrannt die bäume sind
angebrannt es gibt tote ihnen ist alles
egal
aber es gibt auch verwundete und denen
muss man helfen das massaker von ludwina
nur eines von vielen verbrechen der
wehrmacht gegen die zivilbevölkerung wie
die fotos vom september 1939 belegen
das war völlig klar damals dass man
dabei eklatante brüche des
kriegsvölkerrechts beginn von wehrmacht
seite völlig klar
und wenn man sich die proteste der
wehrmacht gegen das vorgehen der ss und
der einsatzgruppen anschaut dann darf
man dabei natürlich eines nicht
vergessen
zum selben zeitpunkt wo die
einsatzgruppen in polen gemordet haben
haben auch deutsche also wer macht's
einheiten in polen gemordet dagegen hat
aber kein general der wehrmacht
protestiert es gibt einzelne stimmen von
offizieren die sagen die truppe ist
außer rand und band wir müssen das
wieder in den griff kriegen
aber die proteste der wehrmachts
generalität richten sich ausschließlich
gegen die konkurrenz von der seite der
polizei und der ss